retournement de situation qui permet
d'envisager un chemin vers la paix en
libye
l'homme fort de l'est libyen avait
quitté moscou mardi dernier sans signer
l'accord proposé par les ministres des
affaires étrangères russe et turc
sergueï lavrov et mev le cas vous chez
oglo en visite à benghazi heiko maas
ministre des affaires étrangères
allemand a confirmé la décision du
maréchal haftar il s'est engagé à
respecter le cessez-le-feu
indépendamment du fait qu'il n'a pas
signé l'accord de cessez-le-feu à moscou
plus tôt cette semaine c'est extrêmement
important
une décision qui intervient alors que la
turquie avait accentué la pression un
peu plus tôt dans la journée
recep tayyip erdogan a confirmé
l'annoncé du 5 janvier dernier d'envoyer
des soldats turcs sur le sol libyen pour
appuyer les forces du gn à de fayez al
sa rage nous envoyons nous troupes dans
ce pays pour assurer la survie et la
stabilité du gouvernement légitime en
libye
sachant que la sécurité de la turquie
commence en dehors de ses frontières
nous continuerons de mobiliser toutes
nos installations politique commerciale
humanitaire diplomatique et militaire
pour la stabilité de la géographie dans
notre sud
l'annnonce du maréchal haftar intervient
donc à quelques jours d'un nouveau
sommet international pour la paix en
libye
une rencontre à berlin sous l'égide de
l'onu à laquelle doit participer manuel
macron fayez al sa rage et le maréchal
haftar seront également présents à la
table des négociations ce dimanche
[Musique]